er braucht man heute gibt es wieder
gremien waren es ist anzunehmen dass ihr
vertreter der afd wieder nicht einziehen
wird warum wir uns überhaupt in dieses
gremium
wir wollen in alle gremien in die wir
recht haben dass wir reinkommen
genau wie alleine fraktion wir wollen
genauso behandelt werden wie alle
anderen auch und das wollen wir
durchsetzen
bei dem bundestagsvizepräsidenten ist ja
jetzt bereits der dritte versuch
gescheitert
werden sie das nochmal versuchen hier im
hohen hause wenn auf jeden fall wollen
wir den vize-präsidenten haben es gibt
keinen grund unseren kandidaten nicht zu
wählen marianne haage kühnel ist völlig
unbescholten wie unsere anderen
abgeordneten alle auch es gibt keinen
grund sie nicht zu wählen es ist von
einer fraktion auch nicht ein einziger
grund vorgebracht worden sie nicht zu
wählen wir haben einen anspruch darauf
der vizepräsident im bundestag wenn er
das plenum führt der kann die das wort
erteilen der kann kritisieren der kann
ordnungsrufe erteilen und wir sind da
nicht dabei das ist eine völlig ungleich
gewichtige veranstaltung hier die es
unfair wir haben können viel zur
präsidentin und das muss sich ändern
sie sitzen ja auch im ältestenrat da
werden sie sicherlich die gleichen
antworten bekommen haben wie wir hier
heute schon von den anderen politikern
nämlich die pdfs haben gesagt ich kann
das ja meinen leuten nicht befehlen den
abgeordneten xy von der afg zu wählen so
ist es ja auch hier das ist formal
richtig aber sie sehen ja egal welche
entscheidung fällt die fraktion
entscheiden relativ geschlossen
egal welche antrag politischer art wie
diskutieren wir debattieren am ende der
debatte wird was abgestimmt die fraktion
relativ einheitlich warum hier nicht
formell haben die anderen recht aber in
der sache natürlich bereden sie wie sie
vorgehen als fraktion
und wenn sie das wollten wie sie das bei
der linken petra pau auch gemacht haben
die vize präsidentin geworden ist
könnten sie das machen
formell haben sie recht aber in
wirklichkeit in der realität gibt schon
den einfluss der fraktionsführung sie
wollen irgendwie nicht bei peter bauer
zum bisschen gedauert bei den grünen
damals ja sogar noch länger elf jahre
waren die ohne vizepräsident
aber kommen wir noch mal auf die wahl
die jetzt gerade dann stattfindet zurück
nämlich für das kuratorium
der stiftung denkmal für ermordete juden
so heißt es richtig haben sie
verständnis dass der ein oder andere
abgeordnete sagt gerade bei diesem thema
sehe ich die fdp und wirklich nicht dort
in dem kuratorium denn der flügel hat
sich da ja in den letzten monaten und
jahren ganz anders geäußert zu dieser
frage haben sie ein anti sie haben sie
ein problem mit antisemitismus überhaupt
nicht lass mich mal darauf zurückkommen
sie haben gerade gesagt die grünen haben
elf jahre auf eine vize-präsidenten
gewartet damals war die geschäftsordnung
noch so dass nicht jeder vizepräsident
haben musste und aus der erfahrung
damals heraus hat man die
geschäftsordnung so gemacht wie sie
heute ist jeder muss einen
vize-präsidenten kriegen deswegen müssen
wir heute auch ein haben das können sie
mir die grünen damals nicht vergleichen
jetzt zu dem thema holocaust mahnmal und
der jetzige uwe witte als ordentliches
mitglied dieses gremium zu berufen ist
es gibt nicht den geringsten grund ihn
nicht hinein zu berufen
keiner von uns hat irgendwie in richtung
holocaust sich despektierlich oder
irgend sowas geäußert selbst führende
hat seine sozusagen aussagen klar
definiert und nochmal klargemacht was
damit gemeint ist und was nicht das sind
alles vorgeschobene argumente die
überhaupt nicht schlagen kann er in
keiner art und weise vernünftig sind nun
das mit biogas äußere mahnmal der
schande dass sie natürlich die meisten
abgeordneten hier im hause anders
deswegen es ist ja auch ein sensibles
thema es gibt immer wieder über griffige
bemerkungen von abgeordneten die
teilweise jetzt auch ihre fraktion und
ihrer partei gar nicht mehr angehören
denn in den letzten monaten das ist
aufgefallen haben ja auch sie als afd
darauf mehr geschaut wer was und wie
sich äußert und sie haben den ein oder
anderen ja auch des feldes verwiesen
also böckelmann mal der schande da haben
wir nun wirklich 50 mal erklärt das ist
unsere schande und das ist ein mahnmal
der schande da ist überhaupt nichts
despektierlich ist dran
da ist bei unseren politischen gegnern
großer wille zum absichtlichen
missverständnis was sie einfach
missbraucht wird in der politischen
diskussion und von daher sehen wir
überhaupt nicht ein warum in dieses
gremium nicht hinein gewählt werden da
müssen wir hinein
aber das wort ist natürlich mächtig wenn
der fraktionsvorsitz vom fliegenschiss
in der geschichte spricht dann zeigt das
schon ein
etwas sorgloser umgang mit diesem
dramatischen kapitel der deutschen
historie
das ist wahrscheinlich auch das
fünfzigste mal dass darauf angesprochen
wird
helgoland hat ganz klar gesagt was er
damit meinte dass der hintergrund ist
möchte auch da nicht missverstanden
werden
er meinte dass diese ganzen nazi figuren
in der deutschen geschichte von ihrem
intellektuellen und moralischen flughöhe
alpha mediokre kleine geringe gestalten
waren das wollte er klar machen nicht
dass diese epoche unwichtig wie sei für
uns oder historisch diese einordnung sei
das hat er nun einmal erklärt auch das
argument kann gegen uns nicht mehr
vorgebracht werden natürlich ist das
eine ganz wesentliche epoche unserer
geschichte sie haben heute ja gesehen
wie gedenkstunde holocaust gedenkstunde
die ergriffenheit ist der
fraktionsübergreifend und ist überhaupt
keine frage dass weder an der seite
stehen wenn man es sich genau betrachtet
herr baumann ist es ja so eine art
ausgrenzung der anderen politiker von
der afg hier auch beim heutigen tag dann
wieder
sie sitzen wie gesagt auch im
ältestenrat sie fühlen ja viele
gespräche mit den kollegen
was kann die afd tun um das verhältnis
ein bisschen so zu gestalten vielleicht
einen anderen kandidaten benennen oder
so zu gestalten dass man zumindest dann
auch mal erfolgreich ist das den
bundesratspräsidenten eines tages an
geben wir haben die kandidaten hahnel
benannt
da konnte keiner fraktion auch nur das
geringste hervorbringen nirgendwo die
ist sozusagen durchleuchtet ist ort
hinaus alle unsere abgeordneten sind in
ordnung aber mariana da an der kühne ist
versucht waren irgendwas zu finden ist
nichts gefunden worden die ist sozusagen
eine super kandidatin die das schaffen
könnte unsere umgangsformen im
ältestenrat oder in der ersten pdf runde
wo wir uns wirklich zusammensetzen sind
absolut bürgerlich republikanisch das
funktioniert ja auch wie das auf die
schiene geht die ausgrenzung versuche
der anderen sind rein politisch
strategisch um zu versuchen uns
niederzuhalten zu diaboli sieren
kleinzumachen zu isolieren schlecht zu
reden das ist praktisch der unfaire teil
des politischen geschäfts aber es nutzt
den anderen nichts
hier kommen ja trotzdem voran sollen sie
mal weiter so machen tut uns leid wir
hätten gerne republikanische
umgangsformen wie sich das gehört
vielen dank